Вау.
[зітхає]
Море...
[чутно, як хвилі б'ються об берег]
Останній раз я у Криму був у лютому 2014 року.
Якраз бачив на власні очі окупацію Криму.
Це Ханський палац у Бахчисараї.
Скільки разів я був у тому палаці.
І приводив друзів туди, і знімав всередині палацу майже скрізь.
Так багато пов'язано з ним,
не кажучи вже про його історію.
Я доволі часто зустрічаюся з молодими людьми, зі студентами,
і у мене є такий запозичений нібито експеримент.
Пропонуєш молодим людям:
«Скажіть, будь ласка, свою першу емоцію,
коли ви почуєте слово "сарай". Кажіть».
Зазвичай дев'ять з десяти кажуть,
що це якась незрозуміла будівля
у дворі, в якій тримають або інструменти,
або те, що вже не потрібно
в головному будинку.
А потім ти кажеш, що з мови твоєї мами
це перекладається як «палац».
І ти одразу запитуєш:
«А якщо я скажу слово "хохол"?»
У переважної більшості так само, як і у вас [відповідь].
Очі набувають сталевого кольору.
Я кажу: «От-от. І що, які емоції?»
Зазвичай хлопці відповідають:
«Ну так нас називають москалі,
коли хочуть нас принизити.
Нібито підкреслюючи нашу меншовартість».
І потім дуже сильно дивуються, коли я кажу,
що з мови моєї мами слово «хохол» перекладається як «син неба».
Слово «сарай» — як «палац».
Кому потрібно було змінювати сенси?
Слово «сарай» і слово «хохол».
Палац і син неба.
Відповідь не просто очевидна, вона прямо волає.
[російською] Я бачу, що це Ай-Серез.
[російською] Ага.
[російською] Мені показали моє рідне село — Ай-Серез.
[російською] Хоча відносно рідне,
бо це село, де [жили] кілька поколінь моїх предків.
[російською] А насправді я народився не там.
[російською] У 1930-ті роки нашу сім'ю розкуркулили,
[російською] тому що у них були виноградники свої,
кілька корів, а це вважалося розкішшю.
[російською] Нас, моїх батьків, депортували на Урал.
[російською] Вони звідти благополучно втекли,
але повертатися до Криму одразу не стали, приїхали в Мелітополь.
[російською] А потім перебралися все-таки до Криму,
[російською] але в рідне село не стали повертатися,
тому що могли повідомити НКВС.
[російською] Вони оселилися у Фрайдорфському районі,
це північний Крим, село Бозкой.
[російською] І 1944 року депортували нас
із Криму саме з села Бозкой.
[російською] Вперше я повернувся до Криму 1989 року.
[російською] Це були роки перебудови, коли вже
[російською] не карали за повернення на свою батьківщину.
[російською] Але тоді тільки не прописували, не давали можливості прописатися.
[російською] І тоді там, у Криму, почався, так би мовити, другий фронт нашого національного руху.
[російською] Ну взагалі російська і радянська пропаганди
завжди представляли кримських татар так,
[російською] ніби між Україною і кримськими татарами
були постійна обстановка війни і ворожості.
[російською] Насправді це було не так.
[російською] Свого часу були набіги з боку кримських татар і так само козаків на територію Криму,
[російською] але це, так би мовити, історія того часу.
[російською] Але культурні, добросусідські відносини
набагато більше перевищують ці обстановки ворожості.
[російською] Зрозуміло, коли Кримське ханство
і запорізьке козацтво були разом,
[російською] тоді й здобували перемоги, тоді легше було й захищати територію України і Кримського ханства теж.
[російською] Скажімо, битви. Конотопська битва як раз.
[російською] Сторінок плідної співпраці українців і кримських татар
значно більше, ніж сторінок воїн і ворожості.
Крим і Бакла — це ялівець, це кримський запах.
Якщо десь закордоном, буває,
чув цей запах ялівцю, [відчував, що] це Крим.
А це ще запах пилу, цих літніх ґрунтових доріг
десь в Скалистому, це теж запах дитинства.
[сміється]
Ми ніколи не повинні про це питання забувати,
воно ніколи не повинно виходити з порядку денного.
Ми повинні про це говорити всюди: і всередині країни, і назовні.
І вимагати повернення [Криму], і працювати на боротьбу
з Російською Федерацією, з цим режимом, який зараз існує.
Для того, щоби відбулися процеси,
які приведуть до деокупації,
а не намагатися вести перемовини з цим режимом,
який просто нам дурить голову.
Розказує щось...
Про Крим вони взагалі навіть не хочуть розмовляти.
Я маю на увазі зараз Донбас, тому що для мене це те саме питання.
Тобто це не треба відокремлювати,
що Донбас — це одна історія, Крим — інша.
Це одна і та ж історія, просто в Криму це вдалося легко,
а на Донбасі не вдалося повністю і далося дуже тяжко.
Ось і все, це одне й те саме питання,
це прояв одної агресії Російської Федерації.
Ми повинні з нею боротися за нашу землю і все.
Клас.
Це мій берег.
Мій пірс.
Я навчилась там плавати.
Радість і сум.
Це називається ностальгія, якщо це одночасно.
Ну, тобто, з іншого боку, то й розумію,
що це місця, де ти ставав людиною,
справжньою, зі своїми сумнівами, радощами, любов’ю…
З усією гамою почуттів,
яка тільки може бути притаманна людині.
І ти зростаєш у цих місцях.
Наприкінці [відео] був інжировий сад, який я згадую як місце…
Місце сили, де мій дідусь збирав інжир,
зараз збирає мій батько.
Всі вже звикли, що є кордон,
потім звикли, що два кордони.
Потім звикли, що обмежена кількість спілкування з Кримом.
Потім звикли, що «добре, вони там залишились, то вони зрадники».
Потім звикли, що цих зрадників постійно чогось саджають у тюрми.
Потім звикли, що «та вони не повертаються».
Потім звикли, що вони просто щезають
і ніхто про них не говорить — звичка.
Оце така погана штука, знаєте, у нас є.
Єдиний рецепт, як змінити ситуацію, — це про це говорити.
Нам вже сумно, нам набридло говорити про війну,
нам набридло говорити про анексію — ми втомились.
Ах, ви втомились...
А як кримські татари повертались після депортації 1944 року?
Скільки років пішло на те, щоб повернутись?
А якби вони втомились? Якби вони втомились?
Я б не знала, що таке Крим.
Якби мої батьки втомились:
втомились від того, що була війна,
втомились від того, що «боже, не кажіть про свою депортацію,
набридло повертатись до сумної історії»...
Якби вони мені так казали?
Все просто пішло би крахом, розумієте.
У мене немає слів для тих людей,
які кажуть, що вони втомилися.
Так буває.
Так буває, і ми маємо бути єдиним цілим, щоб перемогти.
Не буває перемоги без єдності, на мій погляд.
От коли всі йдуть...
Як ми класно зробили, коли був Майдан, га, як ми зробили?
Ми перемогли! Так, ми страждали: кров, сльози — все було,
але ми перемогли, було відчуття перемоги,
скажіть, ну відверто, — було.
Тому ми називаємо цей день Днем Гідності, так?
Ми відчували перемогу, тому що були єдині.
Я впевнена, що супер буває тільки тоді, коли разом
і коли знову ж таки, повертаюсь до своїх думок,
коли є розуміння коріння і майбутнього.